thank you
[Music]
all right this is British woman uh who
makes over 600 bucks a month renting out
the other side of her bed
what wait
600. I know what that means yeah
that's also very low for that action is
that Airbnb in your your mattress yeah
your mattress while she's still on her
side of the bed is she fine
I mean she's not ugly she's charging
she's cute
is it sexual
it better be
do they have like a this is her a pillow
divider
what is it a cuddle buddy
no it's just her side of the mattress
her other side of the mattress what if
you get hard in the middle of the night
and it brushes up against her butt so
that person doesn't live there at all
they just go in there and they sleep in
the bed and then they leave
I guess that's so weird it's called hot
bedding apparently uh this is not gonna
be a thing is that sharing bed share
it's where you rent out the other side
of your beds whoever needs it uh she is
she's a 36 year old actually from
Australia actually not Britain sorry 600
bucks a month is pretty cheap
do you think so for just like half a bed
and not not the apartment well because
but then that's you're giving your
privacy that's kind of knock the
apartment I'm going to use the bathroom
exactly like that should be higher price
right a single person what if it's like
a one night at a time type thing though
like different people can come in at
different times like hostel then that's
even but that's 600 that's 600 total so
that must mean like it's like 20 bucks
every [__] night yeah she's charging
monthly it's the same person also isn't
this kind of terrifying yeah exactly
it's random low price point to put
yourself at that much risk chick now she
says she says hot betting is excellent
for people who are able to detach
emotionally and sleep next to another
person in a completely respectful and
non-strings attached manner it is a
perfect situation especially if you are
a sapiosexual what the [__] is that when
you prefer companionship over the
physical okay now I get it I do think it
takes two people who respect each
other's space values and boundaries to
do hot betting yeah but then like hot
betting can you what about
night farts
it's boring dutch ovens like there's a
lot of things you can't do those are
add-ons
because you can't control that [__] so
you're gonna be trying to sleep and then
[__] next to you is snoring up a
storm shaking the bed with the night
farts to be fair that's that's similar
to a roommate that has like a a separate
bed that might be part of why they like
it though what about sleep apnea
no one's talking about that oh I could
just hear it right now from you but I
can hear it already you know what's
crazy back in the day
um like hotels in Europe when you rent
out like a night right you could be
paired up with someone because the beds
were bigger and then they would sleep
like three to a bed two to a bed [__]
yeah so it was like a air like when you
book an airline ticket and you're right
next to somebody but they would book
like beds that way because beds were
super expensive and people didn't have
their own rooms when I was in Denmark I
stated like a what do you call it it's
kind of a hostel but you get your own
room but then you all share a bathroom
in a shower oh it just has like a
Commons yeah yeah yeah and dude the line
was so [__] long to use the John and
I was holding it for so long I just
ended up peeing in the sink yeah I think
you almost [__] yourself not [__] myself
I didn't [__] in the sink
I would have shot myself anyway
yourself in your own house it's
literally two weeks ago you did that I
did and then I I did I climbed into the
shower with my dirty clothes and then I
washed everything and where was the poop
again Joe oh all over the seat my legs
it was on my underwear on my pants but
where was it Joe
it wasn't on the rug on the road
so basically safe experience is what you
say same thing as my hostile experience
it's nice to have someone that could
relate yeah
it wasn't on the rug I knew that's
interesting it's always like when you
hear these things you're like why would
they do that and then it becomes like a
a subset of like sexuality it's such a
okay
she's like I like the what is that
companionship rather than the physical
actual act like spooning and they don't
want to [__] but they like the like
being close to something I wish I had
that but then how do you how do you
filter out the people that are just like
they just want to be near you and
they're just like I identify as whatever
the [__] you want me to just to be in
the bed maybe there's like Yelp reviews
like on Airbnb you know like they're
like oh great guess they didn't try to
[__] me all night very respectful
dude didn't try to [__] me all night and
said didn't try to [__] me all night it
sounds like Steve would have come up
I like that that because if you're
looking if it if this whole thing is
about hey we have rules we're bed
sharers right yeah and you know there's
like rules like there's orgy rules okay
people don't buy like if you [__] up
with the orgy rules you can't come back
to the orgy sure that's what I imagine
this world to being it's just like
non-sexual like it's the okay yeah it's
like yo maybe there's a word for it like
oh this guy he's like a he's like one of
those guys that pretend to be one of us
but then he'll try to brush his boner
against your back you know you gotta
check those Yelp reviews first or
there's no guarantee that she's not
having sex with them apparently
sapiosexual didn't say anything about it
yeah she could be [__] all of them
she could just be when she said I wanted
no strings attached [__] that just means
she wants to [__] yeah and she said uh
that's what I said when she started this
business uh she actually became single
during covid she's she's like a teacher
uh and her career became unfulfilling as
classes went online to ensure social
distance I got librarian glasses too is
that my life was literally imploding
Beyond My Control I knew my only option
was to innovate and think outside the
box and that's how I decided to do hot
bedding in a moment's thought I
swallowed my pride pride contact capsule
my ex-partner who my hands spoke to in a
year and said to him do you want to
survive covid together and to my
surprise it said yes I've rented to my
previous partner now twice he will be
sleeping with me again soon so like no
guarantee there's no sex here is it just
me like were teachers always [__]
weird or are teachers getting weirder I
think they're getting weirder she's just
renting to her ex-boyfriend so it's not
that unfamiliar she found a little hack
that's a side hustle that's not a
business because that's like saying oh I
started an Airbnb but it's all my
friends and relatives that ran out of
[__] rooms if they're paying rent but
a real Airbnb
what's up with somebody else and now you
lost your whole [__] business yep
I know that's your Prime customer yeah
but it's six I mean 600 bucks a month is
like that's a side hustle though yeah
it's a six I hustle that's how big is
the BET how what's the cost of living in
that town because that might be a lot of
money depending on where it is
600 a month yeah you don't need to
answer that I'm not trying to Nick don't
you yeah I just nicked on it please
that's the room that's a big bed for the
UK oh no this is Australia actually oh
it's in Australia okay never mind it's a
big window I feel like that works in
Australia though I don't know if that
works in the states why because they're
down under I don't know I just think the
mentality is different you know yeah she
should have like different classes
[__] bad mate the economy you sleep
under the bed and then under a bed yeah
economy plus you sleep next to it and
then first class you both sleep naked oh
I like that I like that too no way see
though no AC you don't let it oh never
mind oh wait you need AC I need AC
especially in Australia it's a cooling
bed okay oh yeah it's a very Niche thing
isn't it this is weird that they get to
have sex I mean if it's exactly
everything she says it is and there's no
like secret nasties it's just like so
Niche it's crazy the amount of sharing
we do now is pretty crazy like you know
that like pure space you got airbnbs and
then now they even have like people rent
out their pools at the backyard for just
a little bit Yeah and then there's Uber
but then there's people that can do that
what is the Uber one where it's like
four different people it's cool over
pool and then there's the storage one we
did you can just like keep someone [__]
in your garage for a fee oh yeah there's
the parking somebody else's spot yeah
the amount of sharing we're doing is
insane now yeah that's cool though but
we also live in a stupid world where
they make up some new term like hot
betting yeah but none of those none of
those things can become sexual that's
the difference yeah that's true imagine
you just go to store your boat they're
like I ended up getting [__] over well
you could you could probably [__]
someone in there Liverpool has gone
sexual then then yeah then that can
happen
month commitments though dude like a
month commitment a sleep next to
somebody you you may or may not know
like that's kind of sketchy
it seems like at least with storage
things and all those things it's like a
service that you need but then this is
just something you want to do well
sometimes you need a place to sleep
don't you but they're not unless they're
homeless that's will she take homeless
people what if I'm a tourist yeah I mean
and like I'm taking homeless people bro
I don't want to be at a hotel she's not
taking people that need it she's taking
people that want it yeah but for the
most of human history it was pretty
normal to sleep in big groups it's not
like this is a new idea
now I was thinking about Viking houses
it's just one big house and everyone's
living together [__] and [__] all
in this yeah in the same there's no
[__] same house it's one big long
house and everyone just slept together
and then people be [__] and making
kids and [__] like that so back then
Vikings didn't have any variety of
living there's no privacy it was just
one big house well they didn't invite
invent drywall yet now I have dry logs
pretty nice yeah it's easier to make
dividing areas
they were called Viking long houses why
didn't you pick that article
we already did this one a long time oh
we did that one already quit our job to
become full-time witches is now making
thousands every month that's a way
better article with a better art yeah
this was in May hey host code host code
yeah dude true no PVP I'm sorry
no host on host